the following contains images of graphic
violence viewer discretion is advised
it's unfiltered it's unedited it's
unscripted it's a sense that you're
really getting at who the police are or
what the police do you may have heard
about this tragic police encounter in
st. Paul Minnesota that's where an
officer opened fire on falando Casteel
as he sat in the passenger seat of a car
driven by his girlfriend with a child in
the back Steele's girlfriend has named
diamond Reynolds and she captured the
aftermath of the shooting with her cell
phone and streamed it live to the
Internet we got pulled over for a busted
taillight in the back but you may not be
aware of just how significant this video
is the images Reynolds captured show us
how technology is once again
transferring power from police in the
media to citizens we're waiting for we
already know how influential video of a
police encounter can be the internet is
full of cell phones shot videos from
civilians the cops everywhere regularly
use body cameras to keep citizens and
themselves accountable but the addition
of Reynolds video being live may bring
us one step closer to the truth the
benefit of live video is that it's
unfiltered it's unedited it's unscripted
and anything that could possibly happen
is showing you the truth right there in
pixelated colors dirt level is a
professor of criminal justice at
California State University Fullerton
and the author of good cop bad cop mass
media and the cycle of police reform we
see so many aspects of government
rehearsed and when you can see police
who are our most visible agents of
government performing something in real
time it's a sense that you're really
getting at who the police are or what
the police do but before citizens were
able to keep the police accountable the
mainstream media did it something we got
peek at back in the 1960s when you had
images of police using water cannons and
attack dogs in the south during the
civil rights movement you also had
images of the Democratic National
Convention in Chicago where police
officers were captured in real-time
using billy clubs against anti-war
protesters then by the 1990s handheld
video cameras hit the market and made it
so citizens could be their own news
cameras now the story that mine ever
dove surfaced if someone hadn't picked
up his home video camera we've all seen
the pictures of Los Angeles police
officers beating a man they had just
pulled over you begin to have videos
like the Rodney King videotape where you
weren't dependent on NBC CBS or ABC to
have to go to Chicago or go to the South
anybody standing from a balcony across
the street can capture a police citizen
encounter finally smartphones with
cameras made distribution and
accessibility even easier it's just the
internet on your phone it's a computer
it's an image generator it is a mass
media because we could send one image
not to just one other person on the
other end of a line we could send this
one image out to an infinite number of
people once you had a camera and a
recording device in everybody's pocket
everybody in essence became a news
reporter but as law enforcement became
hip to this trend some officers decided
to take measures into their own hands he
saw me recording and he smacked the
phone on my hand and he yanked it from
me he dropped it on the ground he
stomped on it many times when you see
videos like these it's easy to
appreciate the kind of bravery it took
to film the encounters Eric garner and
Walter Scott had with officers but even
those videos took a few hours or days to
be uploaded to the internet for everyone
to see all of the other videos that we
see are taken from a distance
they're grainy there may not be audio
there's certainly no narration and it's
up to a whole host of Monday morning
quarterbacks to try to figure out how to
make sense of these images the Casteel
video was narrated by someone who was
there and she brings us inside the car
with her he just shot his arm off
we got pulled over on LARPing air Oh dr.
rich friend called to get his hat off he
have you taught him to get his ID sir
his driver's license oh my god please
don't tell me he's dead please don't
tell me my boyfriend just went like that
the video was viewed about a million
times on Facebook before being taken
offline and reappearing with a graphic
image disclaimer but by that time the
word was already out and the local
community began organizing here's a live
look at what is happening right now in
st. Paul a vigil for Phil and El
Castillo what made me record the live
video was God telling me it's your word
over theirs the attention Reynolds's
video got is an indication of her
bravery but also how compelling handheld
live video may be or any new medium for
that matter it does something to people
it takes hold of them it roughs them up
it massages them it bumped them around
that's the late media philosopher
Marshall McLuhan who once talked about
the mediums in which we watch media
being an extension of the senses now
what does that mean a camera is an
extension of the eyes it could bring
things that are far away directly into
the room with us as if we're seeing it
mass media bring government behavior and
bring police behavior that may be taking
place far away and at another time
directly to us in the here and now and
so in that way mass media are
revolutionary because not only do they
render things like time and space and
memory irrelevant but they bring new
information to a public that previously
didn't have access to it meaning that
for a lot of Americans who don't have
habitual interactions with the police
why video may be able to extend their
senses so far as to get a glimpse of the
world where people do yeah you had the
presence of mind to pull out your phone
and do this live stream and I'm in awe
of that would this have happened if
those are passengers the driver the
person will wait I don't think it would
my video may change the way we see
interactions with police but we have to
remember they're just one view of an
event one cautionary tale with the use
of these videos is to assume that these
videos provide enough information to be
able to draw conclusions and we don't
want videos to be used to draw
conclusions about suspects we don't want
the videos to be enough to draw
conclusions about police officers so
while we need to be careful with the use
of these videos more information as
always a good thing
[Music]